فجاه ودون سابق انذار الموت المفاجئ يغيب
الشباب تاركا اسرهم واقاربهم واصدقائهم في
صدمه
الموت المفاجئ غيب في الاونه الاخيره
مجموعه من المشاهير كما اخرهما الفنان
المصري مصطفى درويش الذي توفي امس عن
عمرناهز 43 عاما رغم انه لم يكن يعاني اي
اعراض مرضيه واسباب الوفاه هو توقف مفاجئ
لعضله القلب وهي نفس الطريقه التي توفي
بها عدد من المشاهير قبله ليتصدر بعضها
واسم الموت الغفله موقع تويتر وسط حديثا
لا ينقطع عن الموت المفاجئ وتساؤلات حول
اسبابه
متلازمه الموت المفاجئ باتت ظاهره
المعروفه جدا مؤخرا تصيب المراهقين
والبالغين خلال فتره نومهم غالبا فما هي
هذه المتلازمه ولماذا باتت كثيره الانتشار
مؤخرا الاجابه مع خبيث هنالك عده اسباب
للموت المفاجئ
اكثرها شيوعا هو الجلطه القلبيه الاسباب
الاخرى هو
اختلاج في نبضات الكهربائيه للقلب الاسباب
الاخرى اقل شيء وعدا هو الامراض القلب
الوراثيه
الضرب الشديد في بعض الحالات على الصدر في
حالات ممارسه الرياضه الخليفه والسبب
الاخر هو الصاعقه الكهربائي
وهل يسبق الموت المفاجئ اي اعراض عاده لا
يوجد اعراض تسبق الموت المفاجي ولكن في
بعض الحالات المريض ممكن يشعر في الم شديد
بالصدر او ضيق نفس مفاجئ او عدم انتظام
وسرعه ضربات القلب او ازرق في الوجه
وبعدها يسقط المريض ويفقد الوعي ويتوقف
القلب والسؤال المهم هنا هل هناك من طريقه
لمنع حدوث الموت المفاجئ في الحالات لا
يمكن من حدوثي ولكن ننصح
باجراء الفحوصات الدوريه
للقلب من عمر مبكر لغرض التشخيص المبكر
الى كثير من الحالات
المؤديه الى حدوث الموت المفاجئ